when
you are performing that last scene where
is van der rohe's head at for you when
you're
playing him given everything that
they've all been through
do you think he's he's still in a
position of prioritizing
not spreading the outbreak or is the
fear of that moment and sacrificing his
own life overtaking him
wow what a great question good on you
for that
without giving away too much um let me
see if i can pull off the answer
i feel that you know what was stated
um at the end of that conversation when
scott
ward played by dave um you know
when i'm having that conversation with
he and anna's character about
okay yeah i guess i'll be back in you
know it's not about the money for
for uh vandal it never was it literally
was about
um it literally was about him being able
to have a cathartic moment right and and
next to these people whom he knows and
then of course
here comes dieter uh being thrown into
the
into the bag of you know army and so
we're soldiers uh mates if you will and
so once dida becomes a
fellow soldier a mate trying to figure
out how to aid in
again uh grabbing the prize the money
i think where i'm at in the end of that
movie and the end of the film is
i'm so happy that we accomplished what
we did as a group
as a we as a big team little i and i did
find
the moment where all of the
philosophical um throw outs that van der
rohe of course
you know in in in dialogue written by
zach and our other writer he throws it
out and all of that's there
but does it really stick he throws it
out to
dieter's ear rauhu's character's here
guzman
doesn't really stick but by the end of
the movie i think where i was at
mentally was wow
this is funny the parody of course you
see him laughing because looking at the
mirror at himself it's beautiful that it
was set up for me to have to really
dissect myself
mirror mirror on the wall who is really
the most confused of them all
at this point it's this guy who thought
perhaps he had some things figured out
as much as he knew going in
he um you know still has some things
left to figure out he's looking at
at the end at himself like wow okay so
any of the philosophies that i threw out
do they now work do they save me or are
they just that
and so i think we leave my face in the
form of a question mark
and i think that's where i tried to play
it like this space of
being you know interrogative and not a
period i didn't want to be declarative i
wanted to be a question mark at the end
if my face could be
compared to anything of exclamation um
it was that of a question mark
so that's why i was thinking